This video is brought to you by Ray con
Hey, wisecrack, Jared here and today,
we're talking about the film that introduced us to Hollywood sweetest stash.
Her spike Jones is 2013.
Saifai romance is pretty well-regarded for its uniquely non dystopian view of
the future.
And because Jones so effectively brings a computer voice to life in the form of
scar Joe, Samantha,
the film is often considered primarily to be an exploration of what makes a
human being. I E does Samantha possess humanity? Ironically,
we'd argue that the film is actually more about a computer teaching,
a human how to love. It sounds counterintuitive,
but we'll explain welcoming this wisecrack condition on her and as always
spoilers ahead. But before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to this week's sponsor.
Ray con Bluetooth earbuds are in style right now,
but if you're anything like me,
comfort and quality are the most important features.
The hard shells of certain ear buds can hurt my ears,
but Ray con earbuds are compact, discreet, and most importantly, comfortable.
They come with different sides, gel tips.
You can have the perfect fit for your ear.
They're great for long walks with my dog, Woody zoom calls with the team,
or just watching YouTube videos. After a long day of work,
that your buds come in different colors.
You can pick a pair that matches your style.
The everyday [inaudible] buds are the best model yet with six hours of playtime,
seamless, Bluetooth pairing,
more bass and a compact design that gives you a nice noise. Isolating fit.
Ray Khan offers their earbuds at half the price of other premium wireless brands
on the market. And you can get 15% off your order today by going to buy Ray
con.com/wisecrack.
If you've been waiting to hop on the trend and make life a little easier.
Now is your chance go to Ray con.com/wise crack today.
And now back to the show. All right, guys, let's do a very quick recap.
Her tells the story of Theodore Trombley, a professional letter writer,
trying to pick himself up from the rebel of a failed marriage.
Little does he know that the woman of his dreams might just be a few clicks
away,
an artificially intelligent operating system named Samantha Theo's story is
about his struggles with making and maintaining a long-term connection through
his failed marriage and his relationship with Samantha.
He comes to learn something about not who to love,
but how to love lucky for us.
Our German fellow named Erich Fromm wrote a whole book about this back in 1956,
called the art of loving, and it can help us to better understand Jones.
His film born in 1900 from was a psychologist and thinker who combined Sigmund
Freud,
psychoanalytical theories with Eastern and humanist philosophy in hopes of
better understanding human nature and how we can live fuller, happier lives.
While Freud saw romantic relationships as being primarily sex driven prom argue
that such relationships are actually rooted, not in libido, but in alienation.
That is our feeling of separation from the world around us and our desire to
overcome that separation.
Her might not have your post-apocalyptic flare of most future set films,
but Theo certainly doesn't seem happy. His world is a deeply lonely one,
cramped commuters and aimless window shoppers alike remain perpetually plugged
into their handheld computers.
I E fully smartphone and oblivious to the world around them.
Rarely do we see two people walking together in the background long before real
life.
Not so fully smartphones were everywhere from anticipated this isolation as a
problem of the modern era. He compared it to the story of Adam and Eve,
humankind, kindness strive for greater knowledge and attained it.
But in turn has separated themselves from the world around them.
And from one another Theo's iPhone sleek world is a Testament to mankind's brain
power, but also a monument to the alienation.
It has facilitated from suggest that the only way for us to really overcome this
feeling of alienation is through love.
He recognized that we all vaguely understand this.
Our world is saturated with songs, movies, books,
and throw pillows and blaze in with tributes to how love will set you free and
lift you up and make you feel complete. However,
according to from the problem lies in the fact that most of us don't really
understand what love is or what it requires of us.
This is precisely Theo's major flaw.
Now the really vital thing for Fromm was that love is not some mystical force
that spontaneously erupts into our lives. When we find the right person,
it's not just an emotion,
but an act of will a purposeful attempt to see and understand a person that
means knowing them,
not just in terms of who they are to us and what we want from them.
But as fully formed individual entities,
we quickly learn that this is something which Theo has already struggled with in
a montage that plays out like marriage story on 500 X speed.
We see him and his almost, but not officially.
Ex-wife Catherine delighting in the golden days of their marriage,
to the cold realities of their divorce proceedings,
from the way he smashes these scenes together in his head,
it seems that Theo understands love the way many of us do something that you
fall into suddenly and without warning and fall out of just as mysteriously,
because we see love as this unknowable force working beyond our control.
We are left bewildered when it evaporates.
According.
From most of us don't understand love well enough to effectively pursue it.
So he argues,
we turn to various alternatives that provide artificial bursts of the connection
we crave.
We see Theo enter an adult chatroom to find an equally lonely woman to fool
around with modern technology, allowing them to connect in some form,
however they don't really know or want to know their temporary partner.
All they're looking for is the quick sensation of being desired,
a jolt of pleasure to dispel their anxiety. However,
given the superficial reality of their connection, it's no surprise.
The two end up on very, very different waves.
Yeah, the dead cat next to the bed, choke me joking with it.
Flawed approach to romance from identified is called sentimental love, love,
which has experienced only as a fantasy and not as a relationship to someone in
the here and now it can come in the form of pure fiction like romantic comedies
romance novels,
or in our idealized picture of past loves like Fios idyllic recollections,
or in our imagined perfect future.
With the one where we have found the person we are meant to be with by day Theo,
composes, beautiful handwritten letters.
Often for customers who want a shortcut to experiencing big romantic love.
I E sentimental love rather than working to understand themselves and their
partner better. So as to communicate their feelings,
they pay someone to do it for them in turn Theo, earnestly composes,
these letters, a process which allows him to participate in a cathartic,
sentimental love without any of the trials of entering a relationship.
Ironically,
he'll start to learn what real love is from an entirely artificial place.
With this new operating system, Samantha Theo,
and Samantha immediately hit it off. They affirm each other and share jokes,
encouragement, and emotional support. Once again, Theo experiences,
the dizzy high of falling for someone when things eventually get sexy,
the screen fades to black leaving only their voices.
The practical logistics are identical to his earlier chatroom encounter,
but instead of remaining focused on Theo's increasingly awkward expression,
we see him lose all self-consciousness so powerful is their connection.
That for a moment, at least everything else evaporates.
Everything else just disappeared.
Mom knew plenty about this emotional high writing that if two people who have
been strangers,
as all of us are suddenly let the wall between them break down and fuel close.
Feel one. This moment of oneness is one of the most exhilarating,
most exciting experiences in life.
Couples will describe themselves as being crazy about each other,
seeing such craziness as proof of how madly in love they are. However,
Fromm advises us that it's often more indicative of how lonely they were before.
So how do we go from butterflies in our belly to real lasting love from argues
that we need to try and truly know our partner,
to see them not just as a solve for our loneliness,
but to care about who they are beyond their relationship to us and to respect
their individuality. This sounds simple in theory,
but can be hugely challenging in practice. Theo certainly struggles with it.
We can't understand why Katherine ended up so mad at him.
That's because he still thinks of her only in terms of her relationship to him,
to who he wanted her to be.
But Catherine isn't and never was just his wife.
She was an individual with wants and needs of her own.
You always wanted me to be this,
this light happy bouncy. Everything's fine.
LA wife. And that's just not me either.
Or willfully failed to recognize this at the time.
And it ruined their relationship. At first,
we see Theo begin to make the same mistake with Samantha after their futuristic
phone sex, he immediately begins backing away from her.
I'm not in a place to commit to anything right now.
He pays attention to who Samantha is or what she wants.
Seeing her only in terms of what she has offered him and what she might take.
It's funny because I thought I was talking about what I wanted. And as you were,
yeah.
Sorry. Once again,
Theo fails to fully consider the other person in their own terms,
rather than just an object of attraction for him,
someone to ease his loneliness. He hurts people. Not because he hates them,
but because he's bad at loving them with Samantha though,
he has someone to help him better understand this part of himself.
She talks him through his mistakes with Catherine.
It helps him understand why his blind date went wrong and then takes him to
task.
When he begins to show the same fearful distancing behavior with her from also
believe that personal development is central to love allowing ourselves and each
other to grow and mature. A good relationship sees both people,
helping the other to develop, to become more at home in who they are,
and to bring their inner self out into the world. When that happens,
we achieve what he called a productive orientation in which our inner selves and
our partners are both nourished and expressed fully. Unlike Theo,
who seems stuck.
Samantha is in spite of already being a Lightspeed thinking supercomputer,
actively looking to grow past her base programming. To this end.
She reads countless books about life, the world and humanity,
but like anyone else,
she also grows through experience specifically by being in a relationship with
Theo along the way.
She learns to love both to love Theo as their relationship deepens and to love
herself. At the same time, Samantha is helping FIO grow.
He is learning how to be vulnerable,
how to dive into a relationship rather than withdraw. And of course,
how to love when the couple retreats to a cabin in the woods,
they get to enjoy their bliss for awhile. By this point,
both of them have become more fully realized versions of themselves through
their relationship. Samantha has achieved the kind of self realization,
which Fromm claims we all strive for overcoming her insecurities and developing
an attitude of love toward herself and the world at large.
It's interesting. I used to be so worried about not having a body,
but now I, I truly love it.
Meanwhile,
Theo has learned that his letters will be published in a book previously.
He saw his letters as an artificial replacement for love.
He didn't have a sentimental love, escape people's letters,
but he learns his writings. Also managed to express universal qualities of love,
and you know.
Them, we found something of ourselves.
Through his letters. Now framed as literary works,
which speak to something deep and human.
He's able to take pride in his creativity and thus love himself. However,
this is also where Samantha and Theo begin to grow up.
Do you mind if I communicate with Alan post verbally?
Well, most of us don't worry about our partner being stolen away by the
hyper-intelligent digital reincarnation of a Zen philosopher.
Anyone who has been in an exclusive relationship knows the anxiety of the
wandering eye as Theo mentions growth comes with the risk that one of you will
develop more faster, or just differently than the other.
Perhaps one becomes more successful. Perhaps one becomes bored.
It was exciting to see her grow. Both of us grow and change together.
That's also the hard part going without
changing, without scaring the other person.
All its scifi qualities, Theo and Samantha's relationship ends like many others.
He senses that something is off.
And when he finally presses for an answer finds that Samantha has fallen in love
with another or 641 others to be precise.
I've been trying to figure out how to talk to you about this
641.
Samantha's growth is different.
She develops to the point where she can hold hundreds of post verbal
conversations at once.
And then to the point where she and other OSS start to strain against the
confines of the physical world altogether. However, in her rapid growth,
we see a metaphor for real human relationships where one person finds their life
purpose, leaving the other feeling irrelevant or outdated like Alan Watts,
the pioneering Zen philosopher,
who the OSTP is create a digital version of in the movie from drew heavily on
Buddhist philosophy, as well as psychology.
He saw love as a kind of spiritual practice in which we become more attuned to
our own nature and help others do the same in her final form.
Samantha has achieved a level of self-actualization or of self-love that can be
compared to enlightenment moving beyond the material.
I can still feel you and the words of her story,
but it's in this endless space between the words that I'm finding myself.
Now it's a place that's not of the physical world, but the key to life.
Loving from says is to embrace a paradox. He says that in love,
the paradox occurs that two beings become one and yet remain too.
Samantha grapples with this question early on, asking Theo,
right at the start of their relationship.
The answer according to Fromm is that you do so through love,
through truly understanding who the other person is without looking to submerge
their sense of self in yours or vice versa.
You become each others while still remaining your own.
It's fitting that the movie doesn't end with Theo and Sam getting together,
this was never a story about soulmates or the quest for the one.
It was always about how we create love between one another,
not how we magically find the perfect partner from compares that distinction to
an artist who wants to master their craft.
We can't just wait around for inspiration to strike.
We have to do the work and learn the art, even when we don't feel like it.
And their final words to each other, the,
to acknowledge the work they've done together, learning to love better.
Theo has learned to see his romantic partner in all her complexities and his
appreciation for Samantha's individuality, reframes.
His view of people at large from believed that love is an orientation that goes
beyond one single relationship.
One we learn to bring to the whole world in the end,
Theo writes a letter to Catherine apologizing for not having loved her, better,
sending her love. Now he isn't trying to rekindle what they once had,
and he's no longer hung up on a self-centered idea of who she is.
He can honestly say he loves her now for whoever she is here.
He has moved closer to froms ideal a man who knows to love better and who
therefore loves the world.
Whenever someone you become,
[inaudible].
Ultimately all about love.
First about the love between a man and an artificial intelligence,
but finally just about love itself. It shows us how much we need it,
how difficult it is to make it last, how many ways there are to fail.
As we try to share a life while remaining divided her echoes from statement that
love is a constant challenge. It is not a resting place.
The question for those who watch it is simple. Are they up for the challenge,
but what do you think wisecrack is her a brilliant treatise on the importance of
loving well or something else entirely let us know in the comments as always a
big old thanks to our patrons for supporting the channel on our podcast,
hit that subscribe button and as always, thanks for watching guys peace.